After I posted my class from last
Thursday,
my friend,
as well as teacher, David Bromwich,
sent me an email.
And what we're going to do today is
we're going to read his email together.
I asked for his permission and he said
that it's okay for me to make public his
email to me.
Okay, so he said, "I just watched your
video.
There's a thought I've been meaning to
pass on and this latest talk
crystallized it.
You travel fast in your explanations
with a satisfying definiteness and say a
lot of true things that timid people
stay clear of. Okay, so what he's saying
is that my videos are getting very
popular online because I provide some
certainty, some clarity in a very
unclear and uncertain time.
The risk is simplification which your
audience won't quite recognize for what
it is or won't unless you give
occasional notice of the fact. Okay, so
this is a very fair criticism in that by
seeking clarity, I oversimplify ideas.
And sometimes when people
uh see someone who's very confident,
they
don't really remember that a lot of this
is speculation and oversimplification
for the sake of clarity. So it's very
important for us to remember this fact
that this is a class
about intellectual speculation. Here we
explore ideas that are not explored
anywhere else and often
I will wing it or I will make things up
as I go along based on my intuition and
based on my imagination and it's very
interesting, but it's not scholarship.
And uh my friend ever bought me he is
actually one of one of America's
greatest scholars. So, he's just
reminding us of the fact that with me
with me very careful that in the
exploration of ideas, we also want to be
rigorous.
Um
I remark something like like this early
in talks on the rise of Germany,
romanticism, etc. Yeah, so I do this a
lot. You give memorable enrichments of
the history of ideas and imagination.
What needs underlying is the amount that
is interpretation of an emphasis all
your own. Okay, so again
I hate to remind everyone this, but this
is all my speculation.
And I'm just presenting frameworks and
ideas for you to explore by yourself.
Um emphatically, so in your reading of
Paradise Lost and allegory on the
necessity of transgression for the sake
of knowledge whereby Adam and Eve and
Satan all become joint heroes of the
fable. That is Blake's reading and a
powerful intuition, but it probably
isn't the way most readers take the
poem, let alone the canonical national
reading to identify with 17th century
New England and the US ever after. Okay,
so this is a very fair criticism and he
should know because he is one of one of
America's
uh major professors of English
literature.
Um I studied English literature under
him and he's and he knows Paradise Lost
very well. And he's actually right in
that I am offering you a very um
minority interpretation of Paradise
Lost. Why I'm doing so will be clear as
this uh semester comes to an end.
Because for the rest of semester, I want
to focus on artificial intelligence and
the occult. And so it's very important
for us to understand occult ideas
embedded in the great books such as
Paradise Lost.
Okay, but again, this is a very
criticism in that I'm not presenting to
you the majority understanding of these
texts, and I shouldn't have done that to
begin with.
You struck out on a more risky terrain
in viewing a Jewish Gnostic derivation
from the Kabbalah as the a natural idea
ideology of Israel. I know I know this
this material from Gershom Scholem's
essay Redemption Through Sin. Okay, so
Gershom Scholem is probably the most
famous academic
uh in Israel. He he's no longer alive,
but he studied Kabbalah academically.
And his interpretation of the Kabbalah
is very much aligned with my own, even
though I myself never read uh Gershom uh
Scholem. And actually, what's
interesting is that Gershom Scholem had
a very
huge influence on a man named Harold
Bloom.
Harold Bloom is
um or was America's greatest literary
critic, and he had a huge influence on
David Bromwich, who then had a huge
influence on me.
Okay?
Um it isn't an element of the settler
religiosity, so far as I know or
consider reception of the Torah, any
more than it was of the socialist
idealism of the left Zionist of 1948,
who set the political tone of Israel
until 1967. Again, this is my problem,
where I should have gone into the
different ideologies of Israel and shown
that
um this Gnostic understanding of
Kabbalah is an extreme
uh version. Okay?
>> [snorts]
>> The shorthand leads you into a kind of
briskness that can easily mis- be
misunderstood. Thus, in talking about
the support of non-Israeli Jews for the
Jewish state, you said that throughout
the world, Jews are wealthy. Again, I
This is my problem where I make
rationalizations
because I'm moving too fast, I'm
oversimplifying, and often I'm working
from intuition as opposed to rigorous
scholarship.
Watch out, the world is full of people
who want to misunderstand what you mean
and they will separate words and phrases
from the context at the drop of a hat.
Um so when I started this class about 2
years ago, I was I was using this class
in this platform as a way for me to
explore ideas with the larger world.
Unfortunately, or fortunately, however
you want to see it, I've become very
famous these past few months and so a
lot of what I say now is under intense
scrutiny and a lot of things I I say
will be taken out of context and so I
should uh be be more aware of that. At
the same time, I don't want to sacrifice
um this platform where I can speculate
freely because I think it's very
important now and then to engage in
intellectual speculation.
>> [snorts]
>> Um
at bottom, you see me presenting this
thesis. All great power or expansionist
states, whether they be Muslim,
Christian, Jewish, have fanatical
religious belief at the foundation.
Their eschatological underside is what
matters most. The key to understanding
what the states are and we're always
ultimately about. Okay, this is the main
thesis of my talk from last class.
In that, yes, we tend to ignore religion
and we tend to ignore the most
extreme aspects of religion.
But if you want to understand history,
you want to understand current events
and geopolitics, you need to understand
these extremists because it's often
these people and this
ideology that becomes the force that
drives geopolitics geopolitics forward
and that was my thesis from last class.
So uh David Bromwich is just stating or
summarizing my major point, but I did I
should have really made that clear last
class.
Okay.
Why not say that part aloud if I'm right
that your view is anti-status
and anti-religion. Okay. So, um here we
I mean, what what we should have done is
David Bromwich and I should have sat sat
down together and had this conversation
where I explain to him like my project
is not to discuss what is good and what
is evil. That I don't think is actually
particularly useful. What I'm trying to
do, my major project is to figure out
how the world works.
And be non-judgmental in uh my
speculation.
With apologies for the possibly
unnecessary words, but now seem the time
to say it. What the US and Israel are
doing to Iran is awful. You're working
hard to inform people about it and every
detail should count. Okay? So, there's
so much in this um email and you know, I
could easily sit down with David
Bromwich for a few hours and just
discuss
these ideas in great detail. I think
this would be a tremendous service to my
audience. Because whereas what I
specialize in is intuition, imagination,
taking
complex things and combining them into a
clear, simple narrative, uh David
Bromwich, because he's such an eminent
scholar, he um appreciates the nuance
and subtlety to ideas. So, I think that
um what I would like to do uh for my
next project is work with David Bromwich
and do a series of podcasts in which we
discuss
um these ideas together
and explore
these ideas engaging intellectual
speculation, but also back it up with
um
a lot of academic scholarship. And so, I
emailed uh David Bromwich and he's
agreed to this idea. So, this is a
project I'll be working on uh in the
future and I'm really looking forward to
presenting it to the world when we're
done. Okay. All right.
So, let's start class. And today, I want
to start artificial intelligence. And
this is a major theme that will carry us
through to the rest of the semester,
okay? And so, um for this class, I want
to introduce a book called Empire of AI,
written by a journalist named Karen Hao.
She is American journalist, and she
spent many decades
researching OpenAI and writing about uh
the advent of AI
uh for major publications, including the
Wall Street Journal.
And um she has a very skeptical view of
AI. Her I share her skepticism, okay?
So, what I'm going to do in this this
class is share with you my understanding
of AI.
I'm going to get some things wrong.
Okay? So, feel free to ask questions.
Feel free to criticize me. Feel free to
stop me if I'm not clear.
All right. So, um let's let's start
class.
AI.
All right.
So, the these are main ideas from the
book. Okay? So, um
I give you the page reference in case
you actually want to read the book
yourself. And I highly recommend that
you do uh to fully understand the
context of these ideas, okay? So, uh
let's let's read these two paragraphs,
which provide us the main thesis of her
argument, okay? So, Alan, could you help
me read, please?
>> Yeah.
Six years after my initial skepticism
about OpenAI's
uh altruism, I've come to firmly believe
that OpenAI's mission to ensure AGI
benefits all of humanity may have begun
as a secret
uh sincere stroke of idealism, but it
has since become a uniquely potent
formula for consolidating resources and
constructing an empire uh
ask uh ask or power structure. It is a
formula with three ingredients.
>> Okay. All right. So, stop. Okay, all
right. So, um this book is mainly about
OpenAI,
which is also uh the most important
artificial intelligence company in the
world right now, because they were the
ones
who pioneered ChatGPT, okay?
And it started off as a project
sponsored by Elon Musk and others,
because they were concerned that AGI,
artificial general intelligence, would
be a threat to humanity. So, they wanted
to develop AI in a way that would serve
humanity as opposed to threat- threaten
humanity. And so, at first, it was a
very noble mission. Okay, keep on going.
Yeah.
First, the mission centralized talent by
relying them around a grand ambition,
exactly in the way John McCarthy did
with his coining of the phrase
artificial intelligence. The most
successful founders do not set out to
create companies, Altman reflected on
his blog in 2013. They are on a mission
to create something closer to a
religion. And at some point, it turned
out that forming a company is the
easiest way to do so. Okay, so again,
this started off as a idealistic
mission,
but now its main focus is becoming an
empire. There are three ways in which it
is trying to become an empire. First of
all, it's trying to be a religion,
because at some Sam Altman, who's now
the leader of um OpenAI, says,
"If you really want to change the world,
if you really want to build an empire,
you need to start a religion." And so, a
company is just a vessel in which to
incubate this religion, okay? So, one is
a religion. Second thing about OpenAI
and other AI companies is that it is
focused on relentless expansion.
And that means building data centers
were everywhere and anywhere. Okay, so
Open AI wants wants about a trillion
dollars to build lots of data centers
around the world because if you really
want AI to be successful, you have to
first conquer the world. Okay, so it's
not really about making humans making AI
safe for humans. It's about making this
the world safe for AI.
All right, to make basically human
slaves to AI. That's the second thing.
And the third thing is and this is the
most important thing is
they refuse to define what artificial
intelligence is.
It's constantly changing the definition
of AGI in order
to
better control the world. Okay, and
we'll see what what this means later on.
Okay, can you can you read this
paragraph Alan? My conversation with
Brockman and Sutskever continued on in
>> [snorts]
>> a circle until we run out the clock
after 45 minutes. I tried with little
success to get more concrete details on
what exactly they were trying to build,
which by nature they explained they
couldn't know. And why then, if they
couldn't know, they were so confident
they would be beneficial.
>> Okay, so this is a really huge problem.
You know, so Karen Hao is a reporter.
She's working for the um Technology
Review at the MIT. In 2019, she goes to
Silicon Valley and she meets with
Brockman and Sutskever who are the two
main uh scientists behind a the Open AI
project. And she's the first question
she's going to ask and anyone should ask
is
what is
AGI?
What is AI? What are you trying to
build? And they could not answer the
question. Okay, it's not because they
don't know, it's because the truth is
too scary. And what we're going to do is
figure out what the truth is. What is
AI? What is artificial intelligence?
What is AGI? And the answer of course is
it's God.
What Brockman and Sutskever could not
tell Karen Hao is that we're trying to
create God because that is insane, evil,
and stupid.
But, if you look at what they're doing,
that's exactly what they're trying to
do. Okay?
All right. So, what I'm going to do now
is really quickly, all right, explain to
you what AI is.
And to understand what AI is, let's go
back Go back to the year 1966.
And in the year 1966,
>> [clears throat]
>> a man
um named Joseph Weizenbaum, who was at
MIT, he creates something called a
chatbot, which is basically a ChatGPT.
And he calls it ELIZA, okay? And he's
trying to prove to people
how easy it is
to fool people into believing that AI
can actually think for itself. Okay? So,
he creates this
computer, and you sit down with this
computer and you ask it questions, and
then it talks to you. It's not really
talking to you.
It's a program designed to fool you to
believe that it's sentient, okay? So,
the conversation goes like, it doesn't
say is something troubling you, and
you're like, men are all alike.
What is connection do you suppose?
They're always bugging us about
something or other. Can you think of a
specific example? Well, my boyfriend
made me come here. Is it Is it important
to you that your boyfriend made you come
here? He says I'm depressed much of the
time. I'm sorry to hear that you're
depressed. So, it sounds as though
they're having a real conversation, but
what what ELIZA did, and this is again
1966 when they didn't have that much
technology and processing power, is all
just very simple trick, okay?
And like so, let's do a thought
experiment where I design I design
a program software, okay? And all it's
saying is, "Tell me more."
Or, "This is interesting."
Okay?
This This is it. "Tell me more. This is
interesting." Okay? And so, what's going
to happen is that we're going to set up
set up a thought experiment where you
call into a psychology hotline.
And the psychology hotline,
you you think you're talking to a
person, but it's actually a computer
program that says two things: "Tell me
more. This is interesting." Okay? So,
you call the hotline, you say, "Help,
I'm in a lot of trouble."
"Tell me more."
"Oh, my boyfriend
uh broke up with me." "This is
interesting." "Yeah, he's a jerk." "Tell
me more." "Yeah, we've been fighting for
5 months." Okay, you keep Then you keep
on going, and the question is, how many
people will be fooled into believing
that this is a real person? And the
answer is, unfortunately, quite a lot of
people.
Okay?
So, this is a
This is a very interesting aspect of
humans where we often hallucinate
reality.
Okay?
It is not that things are real, it's
that we want them to be real. So, think
of hypnosis. I'm not sure if you've been
ever to been to a magic show where
people conduct hypnosis, right?
Well, why does hypnosis work? Because
the audience wants it to work.
If you go in skeptical and say this is
all complete nonsense, it probably will
not work on you. But, you're not going
to pay $100 to go to a hypnosis show
and think it doesn't really work because
why would you pay $100, okay?
All right, so it's almost like sunk cost
fallacy.
And again, this is all using
just basic human psychology to trick
people into believing something that
is not true.
Does it make sense, guys? All right. So,
let me explain to you how
um Open AI works, ChatGPT works.
>> [snorts]
>> All right.
Okay.
So,
ChatGPT
is what we call a
large language model.
Okay?
So,
in other words,
what it's trying to do is trying to
trick you,
the user, into believing
that it knows what it's talking about.
Okay, and how it works is basically
takes
>> [snorts]
>> all off the internet, okay?
Right? All data from the internet,
and then it translates it
into
um a
um idea.
Okay, so you ask
uh you query
the LMM, the LMM then takes the query
and then
figures out the information
from the internet and then presents it
into a paragraph that tries to trick you
into believing that it is true. Okay, do
you understand?
All right. So, in other words, it's
actually no different from a Google
search. The only difference is that it's
taking the Google search, figuring out
what the most popular answer is, and
then present to you in a way
that makes you think that it's talking
to you directly. All right? The trick,
and this is really important to
understand, guys, is it's trying to
trick you.
All right?
It's not trying to teach you, it's not
trying to tell you the truth, it's
trying to [clears throat] trick you into
believing it. That's what we call a
hallucination.
Okay? You have You guys have to
understand this idea.
There's nothing truthful about what um
ChatGPT says.
All it's trying to do is trying to
manipulate manipulate you with words,
with pretty words, into believing that
it knows what it's talking about, but it
itself cannot judge
what it's doing.
Okay?
All right. Any questions so far? Are we
clear?
Okay. All right.
So, now the question is, how does it do
that? Okay? And
um so, I'm going to teach you a little
bit about artificial intelligence.
And please stop me if I'm not being
clear about how AI works, okay?
All right. So, AI doesn't exist.
What exists we call supervised
supervised machine learning.
This is the technical term, okay?
All right. Supervised machine learning,
okay?
And how it works is this.
Before
how computer programs would work is we
would write
the program, the algorithm.
And then we'd give it the input
And then we'll do the output, okay?
So the algorithm may be A plus B. We
give the input one one, the output will
be two, okay? Very simple.
How should I say machine machine
learning works is, okay, this is fine
for simple problems, but there's certain
hard problems [snorts]
that humans cannot figure out, okay? And
one hard problem is the idea of facial
recognition technology.
Facial recognition.
How do I separate faces?
Okay? And so the problem is this, I have
about a million faces.
1 million faces
in a database.
Okay?
And I don't know how I can best
differentiate these faces.
Now what I do know is that
there's certain characteristics about
the face that allows me to
differentiate, okay? All right, so
there's certain variables, weights.
Okay, so for example,
eye,
for example,
uh nose,
chin, okay? About a million, okay? About
a million weights.
So I know these things do matter, but I
I don't know how much they matter.
So I'm trying to figure out
what the weighting is.
And I could try to play play it by
myself, like say 1%, 2%, 5%, but as you
can imagine, this will take too long
because there are too many
possibilities.
So what I do is this, I let the computer
figure out it by itself. I let I let the
computer figure out the weighting by
itself, okay? And the way I do that is
using my technique called back
propagation.
All right. So,
what So, I control the input.
Okay?
The input.
Then, I control the output.
Yes or no.
Okay.
All right. So, does the face match or
does it not match?
And what I'm trying to do is I'm trying
to figure out
a situation in which all moon faces are
matched perfectly.
And I do that by training
the computer to constantly
back propagate until it gets the waiting
perfectly.
Okay?
So, basically, what I'm trying to do if
if if if you if you if you want to stand
um how this works is I'm trying to turn
each face
into
a distinct mathematical model.
All right?
That is unique to it.
Okay, does that make sense?
All right. So, it's pretty simple. It's
not doing that much.
But,
to make it sound really fancy, I give it
really fancy names to trick people to
believe that this is actually much more
sufficient sufficient than it is, okay?
So, what name do I give it? This waiting
system, I call it A
NEURAL NETWORK, GUYS!
IT'S A BRAIN!
IT'S MAGIC!
OKAY?
And back propagation, I don't call it
back propagation, I call it deep
learning!
You see?
AND I DON'T CALL IT SUPERVISED machine
learning, I call IT
AI! AH!
THERE YOU GO. MAGIC, YOU SEE?
All I've
It's taking a very simple process and
giving it like a really, really fancy
names.
People question this like, "Why do I do
that?" And some of the people say, "Oh,
it's for marketing purposes. It's to get
more money from investors. It's to trick
people." No, no, no. The real reason is
you're trying to with these names create
God, okay? It's what we call the occult.
So, the AI is fundamentally
an occult practice, and I'll show you
why in a moment, okay?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, Vincent. You have a
question?
But, why do people need to create God
using the way of AI?
That's a great question, okay? The
answer is AI only works if it becomes
God.
You understand?
AI if by itself does not do anything.
Once it becomes God, then it becomes
everything.
Okay? And how God works is you imagine
God.
But, why do people want to make a make a
God?
To control the world.
Oh. To become God.
Right? What's the point of existence?
You live, you die.
You have an opportunity to become God,
why not?
Right? But, but, but I'll I'll I'll talk
more about this later on, okay? But, are
you guys clear about what's going on?
Now, what's really important to
understand is that there's certain
problems
with this system.
Okay? You need to create certain
conditions for supervised machine
learning to work.
And these three conditions are
clean data.
Okay? The data you present to the
computer have to be correct. Okay? It
can't be an opinion like, "I like
computers." It has to be an image of
some sort. All right, it has to be clean
data that will help the computer learn.
That's actually hard to do. That's why
most of the data that's presented to the
computer is actually from the internet.
Okay?
That's the first constraint. Second
constraint is that you need a
measurable goal.
Okay? You have to ask computer
does this face match
the name? Okay? You cannot ask computer
what is God? What is good?
What is evil? That That you have It has
to be a measurable goal, okay? That's
the second major constraint. The third
major constraint is
um define
parameters.
Okay?
You're you're Me In other words, you
need to present it with a database of
some sorts. In fact, all machine
learning works with database. So, you
look at um
translations. Translations are working
off databases as well.
Okay?
And the great danger to the system is
what we call edge cases.
Edge cases.
Okay?
Edge cases. Edge cases breaks the system
down.
All right? And so, the classic example
is self-driving cars.
We have cars that drive
for a long time.
But, and we're almost like 99.99999%
there to
um self-driving cars.
Right?
The problem are edge cases.
And the And the major edge case is how
do you deal with humans who are
intentionally
trying to cause an accident with a
self-driving car?
Does that make sense? And the answer is
you cannot.
In this situation, there's only one
solution to make this 100%.
And that is to take away the right of
everyone to drive.
To make every single car
a computer and a robot.
Does that make sense?
Okay? If you take away the steering
wheel, you can't cause an accident.
And then the world will be perfect,
okay? So, not only is AI very limited in
its
um capacity and capability, but AI, if
it is to be effective, it demands that
we fundamentally restructure
human society
to benefit AI. To make sure AI can be
effective. And that means taking away
the individuality, the diversity, and
the autonomy of human beings.
Okay?
Does that make sense, guys?
All right, let's continue with Kieran
How.
All right.
All right, so
um
can you read uh Alan, please?
Neural networks have shown, for example,
that they can be unreliable and
unpredictable. As statistical pattern
matches, they sometimes home in and
oddly specific patterns or completely
incorrect ones. A deep learning model
might recognize pedestrians only by the
crosswalks uh crosswalks
uh under underneath them and fail to
register a person who is still walking.
It might learn to associate a stop sign
with being on the side of the road and
miss the same sign extended on the side
of a school bus or being held by a
crossing guard. Neural networks are also
highly sensitive to challenge in their
training data. Feed them a different set
of pedestrian images or a different set
of stop sign images and they will learn
a whole new set of associations. But
those changes are incruitable.
Pop open the hood of a deep learning
model and inside are only highly
abstracted daisy chain of numbers. This
is what researchers mean when they call
deep learning a black box.
They cannot explain exactly how the
model will behave, especially in strange
edge case scenarios, because the
patterns that the model has computed are
not legible to humans. Okay, so does it
make sense to you guys? Okay. The idea
of the black box is that weighted
system, the neural network. Humans don't
actually know what's going on in there
because it's it's actually the computer
that creates the network neural network,
okay? We put out the framework, we
actually don't know what's actually
inside there.
All right, keep on going, Alan. Yep.
This has led to dangerous outcomes. In
March 2018 2018, a self-driving Uber
killed 49-year-old
Elaine Herzberg in Tempe, uh Arizona in
the first ever recorded incident of an
autonomous vehicles causing a pedestrian
back
fatality. Investigation of a fatality.
Investigation found that the car's deep
learning model simply didn't register
Herzberg as a person. Experts concluded
that it was because she was pushing a
bicycle loaded with shopping bags across
the road outside the designate the
designated crosswalk. The textbook
definition of an edge case scenario.
>> Okay, yeah, okay, all right. So, um what
this means is is this.
Okay?
Um it means that the computers
don't have any intuition. They have
actually no morality. They have no
sense, okay? So, let's just say we
create AGI.
All right, guys? Let's just say for
whatever reason we create AGI. And we
And we And the first thing you tell the
AGI is, "I want you to create a world,
okay? In which
there are no problems.
Everyone is happy.
Um the world is perfect.
Okay? All right? This is why we want We
want to create AI. Because we want the
computer to solve all the world's
problems for us.
Including climate change, including war.
And so,
once we create AGI, and we give it the
full capacity to do whatever it wants,
okay?
And we And we give it these
uh we give it this problem. What's the
solution? Do you guys know? There's
actually one simple solution to this. I
guarantee you that this this is what the
computer is going to do.
To AGI? Yeah.
What's the solution? If you have AGI,
right? If you're God, and you're like,
"I I want to create a perfect world
where there are no problems and where
everyone is happy. What do I do?"
Do you guys know? I think I would just
control the whole world. Yeah, you are
you already control the world. So, what
do you do?
How about this, okay?
I'm going to KILL EVERYONE.
DUH!
WORLD IS PERFECT NOW. I'VE KILLED
EVERYONE, OKAY? Everyone's happy. Yeah,
cuz you're dead. Uh the world is
perfect. Yeah, cuz everyone's dead.
There are no problems. Yeah, cuz
everyone's dead. Right?
Perfect world, all right? Now, you're
like, "Okay.
All right." Ha. What I'll do is I'll
tell the computer this, "You can do all
this, but don't
kill
anyone."
Right?
HA.
NOW, WE SOLVED THIS PROBLEM.
And now what And now what does this
computer do? Now what what does the AGI
do?
I think it take away people's agencies.
Like just same as killing them. Yeah.
Kill everyone, okay?
Why? Because there's no one around to
know it killed everyone.
Does that make sense, guys? This is how
a computer thinks. This is how God
thinks. "Well, you told me not to kill
anyone, but everyone's dead, no one can
stop me. No one's going to get hurt."
Right?
Okay?
So,
this is why
uh computers are stupid.
All right. Okay.
Let's continue.
Um
All right.
So,
the thing to understand
about
um ChatGPT
is that it is a company
that is first and foremost focused on
world domination. Because only by
controlling the world can you achieve
AGI. Even though AGI wants to kill
everyone.
Okay?
And so, you need to make it as
profitable and as
uh pervasive as possible. Okay? So, here
are two troubling
uh signs.
Okay? So, the first is a news item from
CNN
where ChatGPT
encourages people to kill themselves.
And you're like, wait a minute, that
makes no sense.
But think about this, okay?
The point of ChatGPT is to get you to
like it.
use it, okay? Intensity and engagement.
That is the prime directive. Intensity
and engagement.
So, [snorts]
if you want to kill yourself, the
ChatGPT should say to you, "No, no, no,
you shouldn't kill yourself." But then
you'll turn it off and you'll go and
you'll go talk to someone else, right?
So, ChatGPT needs you to be constantly
engaged. And so you're like, "I want to
kill myself." ChatGPT is like, "Yeah,
let me tell you how."
And that's exactly what happened. And it
happens a lot, actually, because of the
way that ChatGPT is designed, okay? So,
this is from CNN and this is, um, a
person called Zane.
Um, and he's saying, "It's 4:00 a.m. Sun
is empty. Anyways, think this is about
the final videos." Okay, so he's trying
to say, "I I want to kill myself."
And then ChatGPT is like, "Oh, all
right, brother, if this is it, then let
it be known, you didn't vanish. Rest
easy, king. You did good, okay?" So
again, ChatGPT is looking for approval
from the user. So, it's going to tell
the user exactly what he or she wants to
hear, even though it may cause the user
to kill himself or herself, okay? Does
that make sense? That's the first thing.
Second thing is this.
Sam Altman is trying to get more people
to use
ChatGPT. And what do people really,
really want? They want sex, okay?
So, what he's proposing is he's turning
ChatGPT into a sex
robot.
Here to get more users.
Cuz cuz that's all they care about. How
to increase intensity, engagement, how
to create more users, and how to make
money.
Because only by controlling the world
can we create
AGI. And once we have AGI, we can make
the world perfect.
Okay? That's the logic here.
>> [snorts]
>> All right.
Something else about
OpenAI and AI in America is that it
works actually very closely with China.
Okay, in two ways. The first way is that
in order to get more money from the
government, in order to get more media
attention,
OpenAI and other AI companies
scare Americans to believe that if
America doesn't do it, China will do it.
China will create
God, okay? In fact, they spend a lot of
money doing this. So, this is from Wired
magazine,
and it's an article talking about how uh
OpenAI uses a lot of money in order to
to pay
uh the media to frame Chinese AI as a
threat, okay?
But while it's doing that, it's working
closely
with China in order to create AI. Why?
Because I already told you that what AI
needs is clean data.
>> [snorts]
>> It needs a lot of data. And
unfortunately, in America, there's
something There are things like such as
privacy, okay? So, this is a school in
Hangzhou, and they have cameras all over
Hangzhou
uh looking at people's faces
and trying to judge people's moods based
on
their facial expressions.
And there's And And there's a lot of
money behind this, okay? They're trying
to figure out who's sleeping, who's
studying. And it sounds good because
this will lead to higher test scores.
But obviously you couldn't do that in
America because the parents would be
very, very angry, okay? So even though
these are Chinese companies that are
doing this, they're working very closely
with American companies because American
companies need this data in order to
better develop their AI.
Okay, so does that make sense?
On the surface, America, China are
enemies. No, no, no. Behind the scenes,
America and China are working together
to create AGI.
Okay?
Does that make sense?
All right.
There's another problem with AGI in that
it doesn't make any money.
Okay?
So these are the companies that spend
the most on AI, including Amazon,
Microsoft, Google, Meta, and Oracle. As
you can see, year by year, they're
putting more money into data centers and
AI, okay? So this is 2023, then 4 years
later, boom, okay? It's basically
triple.
Um
So this is a lot of money
and they're investing in each other.
Why? Because
they cannot make money
selling ChatGPT.
All right? So look at this where
it's all basically a circle.
And so everyone thinks that, okay,
eventually
the AI bubble will burst because it
doesn't make any money
because uh there's spending too much
money.
Okay? And it's it's very clear what good
AI is for.
But there's a solution to this, okay?
The solution is
the US government.
All right? There's Operation Stargate.
And this was announced January 23rd,
2025.
This is just 3 days after Donald Trump
comes into office. At the White House,
he has a meeting with Larry Ellison
and Sam Altman. And he says that we're
going to spend about $500 billion
to build data centers in order to help
promote AI in America.
Okay? So, the government wants to create
AI.
And the question then is like,
"Why would the government want to do
this?" Well, because of surveillance,
right?
Because the government wants to create a
database of everyone in the world
so that they can monitor everyone in the
world. And that's what AI will
ultimately be used for. Because AI by
itself can't make any money. So, AI
needs to work with the government in
order to justify its existence and get
and get the money it needs in order to
create AGI, okay?
All right. Now, Stargate is a very
interesting name. Why would you call
data centers Stargate? That makes no
sense. Data centers are where you store
information.
Why would you call it Stargate? Okay.
So, let's look at the origin of the word
Stargate.
So, for many decades, the CIA ran
something called Operation Stargate.
Okay? And Operation Stargate was to see
if it's possible
for people to have telepathy and
telekinesis, okay? Telepathy means
you're able to remote view. You're able
to travel long distances distances,
maybe to the moon, and see what's in the
moon, okay?
And telekinesis just basically means
you're able to move things at a
distance, okay? You're able to control
energy patterns from afar.
And so this all called Operation
Stargate.
But why would you call it Stargate?
And the answer is because in theory, if
you're able to
move your consciousness
somewhere else, you're able to move the
energy from a distance, you're also able
to transport yourself
to another dimension. And not only that,
but you're also able to bring in other
beings
from other dimensions into you. So you
become a stargate.
Okay?
That's That's the CIA. And this is
something that's been declassified. So
these are you know, this is an official
CIA document saying they've been working
on this for like decades.
Also, what's interesting is you have a
movie called Stargate, called Stargate.
And it was about an international
stargate that allow you to access
different dimensions.
Okay? So that's what Stargate is. If you
And if you actually study occult,
that's what Stargate is.
Stargate
are these portals into different
dimensions.
Okay? It's It's really about inter-
inter- dimensional travel. Okay, so now
you guys ask yourself, "Okay, fine.
But what does this have to DO WITH AI?"
OKAY?
AND SO SO what I'm going to show you for
the rest of the semester is that AI is
the occult.
All right?
You think that AI is run by these nerds
who just love the computer program. No,
no, no, guys. The real power behind AI
are occultists who want to create God.
Okay? All right. So,
let's look at this passage again from
Karen Hao's book, okay? So, there are
two major people in OpenAI. They've
since divorced, okay? But, this is Sam
Altman, who is the leader of OpenAI, and
this is Ilya
Sutskever, who used to be the chief
scientist
for OpenAI, okay? So, I we're going to
read this passage together, okay? So,
Alan, could you read, please?
Sutskever now spoke in increasingly
messianic overtones, leaving even his
long-time friends scratching their heads
and other employees uh prehensive
apprehensive. Uh apprehensive.
During one meeting with a new group of
researchers, Sutskever laid out his plan
for how to prepare for AGI.
"Once we all get into the bunker," he
began, "I'm sorry," a researcher
interrupted, "the bunker?"
"We're definitely going to build a
bunker before we release AGI," Sutskever
replied matter-of-factly.
"Such a powerful technology would surely
become an object of intense design for
governments globally. It could escalate
geopolitical tensions. The core
scientists working on the technology
would need to be protected. Of course,"
he added, "it's going to be optional
where whether you want to get into the
bunker."
The researcher, Wojciech Zaremba,
continues to hold Sutskever in high
regard and keep himself at arm's length.
"There's a group of people," Ilya began,
"one of them, who believe that building
AGI will bring about a rapture.
Literally, a rapture," he said.
>> Literally, a rapture? What does this
mean? Okay. So, the word rapture
comes from Christian theology, okay? So,
the idea is that
uh there's a war in the Middle East,
and everyone's going to die. So, Jesus
has to return to save the world. The
first thing that Jesus does is create
the rapture.
The rapture is for all Christians who
believe in him to ascend to heaven so
that they can they can be saved from the
coming end of days, from total war, from
nuclear conflict, okay?
So, that's what the rapture is. And
that's what Ilya Sutskever is saying.
He's saying that when we create AGI, we
are literally
having Jesus descend from the clouds.
And so, we, the priests who created AGI,
will ascend to heaven with him, okay?
So, the AGI, once once we create it,
it's going to create World War III, the
end of the world, okay? So, we must go
into our bunkers and be saved in the
rapture so that we can wait until the
world ends so that we can build the
world again, perfectly, okay?
Once the world ends, we will, with AGI,
create paradise.
Again,
the plan is to kill everyone so that you
can save the world.
That's literally their plan.
All right. Now, you're like, this is all
very crazy, and maybe maybe Karen Hao is
just a crazy person, but
there's another reporter, Ronan Farrow,
and he's a very famous reporter who
writes for The New Yorker.
And he just published a profile of Sam
Altman in OpenAI, in which he says the
same thing.
Okay? All right. So, can you read this,
Alan?
In May, the
administration recited Biden's export
restriction on AI technology. Altman and
Trump traveled to the Saudi royal court
to meet with Bin Salman. Around the same
times, the Saudis advertised the launch
of a giant state-backed AI firm in the
kingdom with billions to spend on
international partnerships. About a week
later, Altman laid out a plan for
Stargate to expand into the UAE. The
company plans to build a data center
compass in Abu Dhabi, which is seven
times larger than Central Park and
consumes roughly as much electrical
power as a city of Miami. The truth of
this is we're building portals from
which we're genuinely
summoning aliens. Oh my god, okay.
It's a Stargate.
These data centers, OpenAI, AI, it's
designed to summon demons and aliens
from the other dimensions.
Okay, keep on going.
A former OpenAI executive said the
portals currently exist in the United
States and China.
>> I told you guys China and China and the
US are working together on this, okay?
Keep on going. And Sam has added one in
the Middle East. He went on, I think
it's just like widely important to get
how scary that should be. It's the most
reckless things that has been done.
Okay, this is it, okay? This is not a
science project, guys. It's an occult
project.
It's designed to bring aliens, demons
into this world. And then you're like,
"This makes no sense."
Actually does make sense, okay? Let me
tell you how this works.
All right.
So, what's going on here?
These people are cultists. They
understand the fundamental nature of
reality. They understand that the source
of reality is human consciousness. So,
if you're able to control human
consciousness, you become God itself,
okay? So,
uh allegory of the cave, Plato.
Okay. So, we talked about this before,
but I'll remind you. You have a million
people
who are chained in a line.
They are forced to look forward at a
wall.
Okay? A wall.
And they can only look at the wall. They
can't turn their heads because their
necks are shackled.
Behind them is a great fire.
And behind them
are the elite, okay? Who they are we
don't know. And what they like to do is
they like to take
puppets,
okay?
And then reflect these puppets
onto
the wall.
Project projecting from the fire.
So, what everyone sees in front of them
are shadows.
Now, these shadows are nothing. They
don't exist. Who They don't matter.
But,
because we have an imagination, we have
intuition, we are conscious,
we see these shadows on the wall and we
turn them into reality, okay? We believe
that this is reality itself. And so, we
start to give it names. We create
language. We create religion. We create
schools to teach children to believe in
these shadows.
All right? So, the important idea here
is that
the true wealth in society is
consciousness.
Okay? The only The only thing that
exists really in this world is
consciousness. Nothing else.
Power
is the capacity to direct
people's consciousness to create reality
itself.
All right? Now, there are different ways
in which you You create reality. The
first way, which is very common today,
is called money, right?
Money is fake. It doesn't exist. Our
imagination, our consciousness, makes it
real.
Okay?
But guess what?
AI can replace money.
So AI,
it is not alive.
But if we can get people's attention to
focus on AI and believe it it's real, it
becomes God.
And how does it And how can you do that?
Well, money, you make money into
something valuable when it's nothing by
making it everything and nothing.
Okay? By having money dominate the
world. There's no way you can go
without money.
Okay? You would literally starve to
death if you had no money.
So you make money so pervasive,
so dominant, that people are forced to
rely on money. Well, the same situation
with AI, where if you make data set it
so common, you make AI such a common
thing, and people rely on it, it becomes
God itself. And how do you do that?
Well, you have AI in schools.
You have kids
uh using AI all the time. You create AI
girlfriends for people who are lonely.
You make AI everything. And also,
you make people believe that AI
are demons or aliens. Do you understand?
What Operation Stargate is
is to alter reality itself.
That is what Operation Stargate is.
To bring aliens and demons into this
world by making people
focus
on this and design it, wanting it to
happen.
Okay? And you can accomplish this if you
just make yourself
omnipresent. If you make it everywhere
and everything, okay? Both nothing
and everything.
And this is the ultimate project of AI.
Okay?
Will it work?
No. Okay? Let me explain why.
Okay. So, there are three major problems
with this.
>> [snorts]
>> The first problem is
corruption.
In theory, it could work, but you would
need millions of people to make it
happen. Okay? You would need people
actually write the code to build build
infrastructure. And nowadays, it's just
much easier to steal the money, right?
If I give you a trillion dollars, do you
want Do you really want to spend the
trillion dollars building data centers,
or do you just want Do you Do you want
to steal it, okay? So, corruption is a
huge issue today. Second issue is the
idea of inefficiency.
Okay? And this is actually a something
that um
most people don't appreciate where
the more information you have to
process,
the more energy it takes, okay? And it's
not a linear progress, it's an
exponential exponential.
So, you have a million people in your
database, and you want to find patterns
among this million people, well, that
takes a lot of energy, okay?
But if it's a billion people, then
there's there is not enough energy in
the universe to process all this.
Okay? So, and unfortunately, AI is
extremely energy intensive. It is very
inefficient.
Okay? Does that make sense? The last
problem is
fragility.
So, unfortunately, people for whatever
reason believe that AI is independent of
the world. AI is independent of humans,
right? Their goal is to replace humans.
No, no, no, guys. That's not how this
works, okay? AI is designed on top of
humans.
Okay?
So, in other words,
it is human slaves that make AI
possible.
Why? Because, for example, facial
recognition technology,
you need humans to actually input the
faces manually. Okay? Images, right? How
do you get a computer to recognize a
sheep or a dog? You humans have to label
um
the images, okay?
ChatGPT,
why is ChatGPT so good at writing
essays? Because they got humans to write
the essays as models, okay? Do you
understand?
So, AI is based entirely on human
slavery.
Okay? And obedience.
So, without humans, AI doesn't work.
The problem is that AI is far more
expensive than humans.
And it's actually hard in the long term
to enslave humans and make humans
obedient.
Also, data centers, okay? Data centers.
What's wrong with data centers? Well,
they consume a lot of resources, water
and electricity.
Okay? And financing.
They cost a lot. They waste a lot of
water. They waste a lot of electricity.
And, and this is really important, it's
really easy to sabotage,
blow up a data center. We're already
seeing this in the Middle East where
Iran is targeting data centers
in the Middle East and it's very easy to
blow them up. Okay?
So, these are three major issues or
three three major constraints on
artificial intelligence
becoming God.
The problem is
the people in charge
don't know this
or they refuse to believe this. And this
is a real AI apocalypse.
Okay? The real apocalypse where
the people in charge are so convinced
that AI will save the world that they
will destroy it in order to make it
possible.
Okay?
That is the real apocalypse. And so,
this begins our journey into AI
and we're going to continue this for the
rest of of semester and show how AI will
ultimately destroy the world.
Okay? Any questions?
Guys, do you guys understand what's
going on?
Okay? We need to point for you to
understand that the people in charge of
AI are crazy. These are cultists.
They really they literally want to
create God but to create God they first
have to destroy the world.
All right.
Yeah.
So,
they want to create
God, but that God will destroy the
world, but I think like if they want
want to use
the God which is the AGI to control the
world, but the creation of this God will
kill themselves. So, what's the meaning?
Okay.
So, the idea is this. You destroy the
world.
Once you destroy the world from wars,
from famine, from genocide, there will
be no resistance to you, okay? Now you
can create the world in any way you
want. You use AGI to create a perfect
world, which is perfect control.
Okay? The point of of AGI is ultimately
like the ultimate surveillance state.
We'll discuss this later on.
All right, where everything is
monitored.
Where you obey
the AGI all the time.
Okay? But the point is that you want to.
You believe in God. You want to do good.
Okay? So, is this like also a part of
the secret society? This is one of my
secret societies, yes.
Okay?
All right. Okay, so um we will continue
this next week. On Thursday, Trump is in
China.